it was really rough for quite quite an
extended period of time we couldn't pay
our mortgage we had cars repossessed
i've told this story before but
it was so bad at one point
that you know we didn't have enough
money to pay for our
our
garbage collection so they took away our
bins we had to put our our garbage bags
in the back of this beat up minivan that
we had and look for you know kind of uh
bins like behind the grocery stores and
stuff to like throw our garbage i mean
it was pretty humiliating and quite
frankly pretty emasculating as somebody
who's supposed to be
you know head of household and taking
care of [__] like i was unable to make
sure that my house was in order and so
we went through a really rough period of
time and
it was not clear that we were going to
be able to kind of persevere
[Music]
okay so let's give you a little intro
here so we got uh rich roll which is um
an amazing name first of all i'm sure
you get that a bunch
i feel like the rick roll kind of
stepped down your corner a little bit do
you get is that a problem for you a
little bit man not a day goes by where
you know i'm not on the receiving end of
some kind of bs about that
yeah exactly
um
and but that is your real name rich roll
that is like not like a stage name
god-given name okay wow my parents are
are uh you know behind here so
uh and you have a very very interesting
story so i'm gonna give the like very
laymen version of the story
um and then we what i wanna do is two
things i want to dive in and actually
hear from you a little bit more about
the interesting bits of that story as
well as you know it's we are kind of
like a we're a business podcast and so
what we'd like to talk about in general
is
um business opportunities sure sounds
good all right cool um so your story is
as far as i know is as follows you
um
you're coming up all you were coming up
on 40 years old
um
you were not in great shape you're i
think 50 pounds overweight is what you
what you say and
you
were you know decided to sort of make a
change in your life and now you are very
very well known
as a
endurance athlete who
has a plant-powered or vegan diet and
you have done some kind of amazing
things in the endurance
uh you know competitive endurance field
i think you were named one of the 25
fittest men
on the planet by men's fitness which is
a pretty dope honor um and so that is
your kind of that's your claim to fame
did i did i get that right
yeah i think that's that's fairly
accurate that's probably how i'm best
known although i haven't raced in a
number of years and i've sort of
graduated or i'm attempting to kind of
graduate from the limiting parameters of
being known as like a vegan endurance
athlete and the podcast is a big piece
of that which we can get into but i
would say that's a fair assessment of
how kind of most people think of me and
and my association and what would be the
shift so if you were known as like this
guy who went from i guess the full story
is entertainment lawyer
uh you know struggle with sort of drugs
alcohol get sober then you're but then
you're overcompensating by eating not so
great and then you have this kind of
moment you're you know you're sort of uh
your
you know come to jesus moment or
whatever where you're like okay i'm
gonna make a change you make this
lifestyle change you become this
well-known uh endurance athlete who's
doing it in a way that's atypical so i
think you're the first vegan to complete
a
ultra endurance event which is like some
crazy 300 mile
uh 300 mile type of event uh where
you're running you're biking you're
swimming you're doing all that good
stuff and now
you have businesses that are around this
right so you have a meal planning
business you have um
there's kind of like a whole lifestyle
uh and brand and business around this
stuff and so
from going from i'm known for competing
in this what do you think you're what do
you want to be known for now what do you
think is that transition
yeah it's a great question i mean i
think that uh
you know just kind of fill in the gaps
on the story i do have a history of
you know alcoholism that's a big part of
my story alcoholism and recovery that
predated the kind of
next chapter which was uh sort of middle
age malaise and reaching another kind of
rubicon with how i was living my life
and making a secondary transition into a
healthy lifestyle and that led me into
the ultra endurance world and i was able
to distinguish myself in that world
as a middle-aged athlete but also as
somebody who was doing it plant-based
and that garnered a fair amount of media
attention and put me in a position to do
something with it and the first thing
that i did was write a book
uh it came out it came out almost
exactly ten years ago it was called
finding ultra and it's essentially a
memoir but it also has aspects of being
a bit of a lifestyle guide and that kind
of put me on the map in a public way
and in the wake of that book coming out
it became about like okay
that was great i got you know an okay
advance for that but i've got four kids
how am i gonna make a living
um sort of propagating these ideas or
continuing the conversation that that
book began because up to that point i
was still a practicing attorney and so
the transition
out of the legal world into doing what i
do today
i would say has been a very inelegant
and protracted process i'm not a
naturally
uh inclined entrepreneur i was reared in
a in a in a much more kind of
traditional conservative environment
education first get the good job get
into the good grad school the whole bit
and hence you know became a lawyer which
is you know very much a safety seeking
type of career so my mindset and my
thinking has never been oriented around
entrepreneurship whatsoever but i
suddenly found myself in the position
where
being a lawyer
felt uh untenable given all these
experiences that i had and i was given
this gift this opportunity to do
something different and it really
challenged me to uh upend uh all of my
kind of built-in proclivities around
safety seeking and kind of doing uh kind
of following
this
um
you know path
that society smiles upon like even
though i went to stanford and was
surrounded by entrepreneurship and the
explosion of silicon valley for some
reason that never rubbed off on me
and i and and and now i was in a
position of like okay i need to
kind of shed the limitations of how i'd
lived my life to date and really start
to think about how to do this
differently and
because it's not my
natural state i sought out mentors and i
found one mentor in particular who's
been absolutely instrumental
in helping me forge this new path his
name is greg anzalone and he's ceo of a
company out here near where i live
called sideshow and sideshow
is
a pop culture collectibles company
they create
uh
figurines like limited edition
uh very uh finely crafted
um figures from pop culture so from the
marvel movies and star wars etc
everything from
life-sized uh c-3 c c-3pos to darth
vader's and thor and the like and he
grew that company from
a couple artisans in a garage to now a
very large enterprise that employs
hundreds and hundreds of people and if
you're to go to comic-con they have the
second biggest booth at comic-con second
only to marvel and there's a whole
subculture of people who are fanatic
collectors of what sideshow produces my
point being that greg is a natural
entrepreneur he's been very successful
in a number of businesses
and he began to mentor me and retrain
the way that i was thinking about my
life and really helped me create
structures around what i was doing and
strategies in order to
build a foundation upon which we could
create a sustainable business that would
provide for my family the book was the
first piece in that in the wake of the
book coming out and in an effort to
continue the conversation that that book
began i launched the podcast almost 10
years ago so
i wasn't a first mover in the podcast
space but i definitely
was an early adopter and it was a medium
that i had fallen in love with as an
athlete i'd spent so many hours so much
time alone on the bike and running
listening to podcasts when it was very
difficult to even acquire an episode it
was pre iphone so you had to
go to your desktop or your laptop and
download a series of mp3s and then
bounce those mp3s to your ipod and
create playlists and i was doing this
before anyone else i knew was listening
to podcasts and was discovering as we're
all discovering now how much value there
is in this medium and so with that love
and i think a lot of
not practice but i was very acclimated
to
what a good podcast could be because as
a listener i'd consume so much of this
media
that when i started mine i felt like i
was in a situation where i had something
to say i knew some interesting people in
my life and importantly there wasn't any
competition at the time like people were
not clamoring to start podcasting
in 2012. i think you know
aside from uh adam carolla and kevin
smith and and maybe joe rogan nobody was
even monetizing these things so it was
less about it being a business
proposition
uh and more about uh an opportunity to
continue to build a platform with the
trust that at some point
something could come out of this that
could sustain my family financially and
so
i started the podcast i immediately was
able to rise to the top of the itunes
rankings because as i mentioned earlier
there was no competition at the time and
in the health and fitness and wellness
space there really wasn't very
much good content at the time so
from that i was able to build an
audience slowly and gradually over time
and did the podcast for a number of
years before monetization was even
anything to to consider
um and now of course it's it's you know
it's doing incredibly well but again
that wasn't really the plan but because
the podcast has become and continues to
this day to be
the tip of the spear uh in terms of all
the things that i do
it's been the most profitable not just
financially but also in terms of
engaging the most number of people
around the ideas that that i care about
and this has been a very long-winded way
of getting to the point of answering
your question which is how do you want
to be seen today
very early on i i made a decision from
actually from the outset of the podcast
that i didn't want it to be a podcast
about
specifically just being plant-based or
being an athlete i didn't want it to be
a triathlon podcast i wanted to cast a
wide net which is why i named the
podcast after my name because i wasn't
sure if i was going to continue to do it
where my interests might find me but i
knew that i probably wasn't going to
change my name so i just did the easy
thing and named it after myself
and it's allowed me the flexibility to
move in whatever direction inspires me
and so
although i would say that the core kind
of themes of the podcast are around
personal transformation healthy
lifestyle eating and of course
fitness running you know the sports that
that i care about it's also allowed me
to
host conversations with just a wide
diversity of people who i can continue
to grow from um in other ways beyond
like how i've been traditionally
known because for me this is my growth
accelerator and i think we're all here
on the planet to grow in our various
ways and overcome our challenges and so
it's given me the opportunity to sit
down with people who can help me
grow and work through my you know kind
of limiters in
in all areas of life and so as a result
it's allowed the audience um to be very
diverse although there are plenty of
kind of you know vegans and runners and
stuff like that it's really brought in
all walks of life and i think has been
um a big reason why the podcast has
continued to grow and flourish because
it's not limited to one specific theme
topic or
kind of uh heading
and how big is it today so i see on
youtube maybe like 700 000 subscribers
there
uh podcast i'm not sure what that would
be is that i don't know if it's bigger
or smaller than the youtube stuff and
then the top videos like you know david
goggins hubermann those who get like
five to ten million views on youtube
which are great kind of like the
you know the perfect storm of like
overlap of interest the right guest who
already has their own audience
people search for their name in youtube
that sort of thing so how big is the
give us a sense of how big the the kind
of the the content side has gotten to
now
yeah so
youtube has been something that that
we're relatively new to i think we
started uh filming the podcast in
earnest maybe two and a half three years
ago at this point um and like you said
we have outlier videos like the
hubermann
initial huberman podcast i did i think
has like 11 million views some of the
goggins interviews have a lot of views
but a lot of them don't have that many
views so it's very hit or miss and as
you know
uh youtube is all about the algorithm
and what's great about youtube is that
it's amazing at discovery so it allows
people who are not subscribers or people
who are not familiar with what you're
doing to kind of ha by happenstance
stumble onto your content and and it
allows you to then bring them into your
universe
but youtube is still a very small piece
in our content engine the vast majority
of our audience is audio only so through
apple podcasts spotify is a very small
very tiny slice of our audience so the
vast majority are people who are
listening on apple devices or on
platforms that are outside of spotify
and youtube but i believe in youtube
because even if somebody doesn't watch
our video
that thumbnail might come across their
screen and it almost works as a
billboard to enhance visibility um of of
what we're doing and so we continue to
invest and double down in youtube
although the core of what we're doing
really is um audio first at least now
i'd probably i'd say it's probably
anywhere from 90 to 95 of our audience
oh wow okay so this podcast is
probably very huge then so like you know
probably getting
i don't know half a million
you know listeners per per thing then
something like that
yeah it's it's in that range i mean as
you know like on in audio it's fairly
predictable uh how large the audience is
going to be and how many people are
going to listen um you know there's
going to be some variation there but it
falls within a tight range whereas in
youtube it's just all over the map
because
the algorithm gods can smile on you as
they did with hubermann and it goes wild
that doesn't happen in audio uh so yeah
i mean you're correct it's about in that
range on average and so um so i have
this theory with content which is that
uh people will ask me a lot like okay
you know how do i do better how do i do
a good podcast how do i grow my content
how do i grow my audience
and i say well there's some like you
know they're kind of looking for the
what do i write in my title or thumbnail
or like you know something there and
there's definitely things that are
better or worse
but i would say you're an example
of
the core fundamental of what works so
let me say three i'm just gonna point
out three things of what you gave a kind
of good story i'm gonna point out three
highlights that that of why this worked
number one you were early to a platform
that ended up being big um if you're
late to a big platform it's tough if
you're early to a platform that never
gets big
also no bueno you gotta have early to a
platform that's big that is one of the
best things you could do to increase
your odds of success you were basically
listening to podcasts just when it was
rss you know only or whatever maybe even
you know there's no players or whatever
um okay so the second thing is
you um you have a you had a niche where
you built authority
um so like let's say initially it might
have been
vegan lifestyle or endurance training as
a vegan something like that right like
the overlap between two
hyper passionate niches which is like
you know plant-based lifestyle and you
know performance uh you know athletic
performance and so that overlap was like
a niche that you could kind of dominate
and become the authority there because
there just weren't that many people who
are doing it you know in general forget
even about podcasting
now on topic in addition to the kind of
addiction recovery piece is also a cool
aspect of that as well and so that's
that's what's gonna go next which is i
think you have an innate understanding
that
story is what gets people hooked uh like
for example when you came on i was kind
of describing you with just like some
labels like there's some descriptors
you've accomplished this you're known
for this and you were like uh you
brought it back to story what's a story
a story is some transformation or change
uh you know the protagonist the hero
goes through something uh and they
started one way and they change into
another way they started thinking one
thing and then they realized another you
know they started single they ended up
happy in love right that's the basis of
all stories some
change some transformation and i think
as i heard you talk about like whether
it was from
risk-averse lawyer to reluctant
entrepreneur who learned to shed that
limitation that's change uh you know
meat eater to plant eater change uh
overweight to
you know endurance athlete change and so
i think you're really good at framing
change because
the fundamental thing people want more
than learning how to you know whatever
swim 100 miles is like everybody a
broader thing is everybody wants to
remove some of their limitations and hit
that transformation that they crave
whatever that is and they could take
inspiration and and knowledge from your
story so i think that's another one
the last little element i like that you
said is i think you have what i call the
red pill which is
uh you
have uh opinions or beliefs that might
be might run counter to like the
consensus opinion right uh i think in
general uh vegans have a
belief about diet and lifestyle that is
counter to the mainstream behavior and
so when you have that like you know that
point of view that is a different thing
uh it grabs people's attention and it
gets them hooked and the people who for
whom that resonates uh it kind of like
you know they become attracted to that
so i don't know i'm not saying you
intentionally architected these things
but
just out of your story about how you
built this pretty remarkable kind of
content franchise i just wanted to point
out some of those elements that i've
seen be common elements for people what
do you think of some of those
yeah i mean i think that's fairly
accurate in astute the only the only one
that i would bristle out a little bit is
the red bull red pill thing i think it
is of course like to be vegan and to be
an athlete there is something contrarian
about that um the only kind of nuance
that i would add to that is that i i'm
not somebody who's out there seeking to
kind of game the system by being
controversial i'm not yeah i'm not
inviting controversy or trying to get
into debates with people i share my
experience and i'm always very careful
and this is something that i've learned
in recovery to not be overtly telling
people what to do or how to live their
lives it's always back to story as you
point out because i think that people
learn through stories you could tell
people here are the five things you need
to do or you can have a guest on who
says here's the roadmap to achieving xyz
and i've just learned for myself and in
terms of you know how i've conducted
this podcast over the years that
although we can intellectualize those
answers or those principles we're very
remiss in putting them into action
unless we can emotionally attach with
them and that's where story comes in and
i think as content creators we're all
storytellers and it is our job to refine
our ability to tell a story well and if
we can do that and do it in a way that
allows us to be
relatable and also make the guest
relatable such that an emotional
attachment not just to the outcome of
the story but to the individuals who are
participating in that story that creates
a level of engagement that actually does
um
that does result in powerful and
sustainable change because the mission
of the show really is to help activate
transformation in the audience members
so whether it's going from addiction to
recovery or changing your diet or
lifestyle habits to go from unfit to fit
or to accomplish a hard task all of
these are just
metaphors analogies or examples of
transformation i think everybody's
looking for some kind of transformation
in their life so it's not about like how
do you go out and and do an ultra
endurance race that's just one vehicle
for transformation it's my personal
story and i'm happy to tell it but i'm
really about getting to the core tenets
of why some people change and others
don't and trying to find
a means by which i can communicate a
path for people to rethink the ceilings
on their own limitations and invite a
little bit of challenge discipline
and uh and you know kind of goal setting
into their own lives so that they can
experience some version of the
transformation that i've been lucky
enough to experience in in my own life
and then the final thing
um that i would point out
you kind of uh launched into this
question
with uh a little treatise about you know
titles and how you you know kind of
position your content on the internet to
try to game it for success
and of course you know there are kind of
tenets and rules around like here's if
you want you know a lot of people to
click you say it this way or you have
this crazy thumbnail and i'm not saying
we're immune from experimenting with
that but i think the core principle that
i would like to communicate to you and
your audience is that you know in my
opinion over the kind of long arc of of
time
quality is what wins and so i try to
uh opt out of a lot of these trends of
the moment and just focus on creating
the most powerful the best content with
the best guests that i can find
and and and kind of put it out there
and trust that um
that it will find the audience that it
needs to find now that's perhaps a
little bit of a luddite you know kind of
approach to this and it certainly isn't
going to um
you know create viral moments but as
somebody has been doing this for a very
long time and has kind of seen and
weathered all the changes in media that
that seemed to take place with even
greater
a greater increase in in rapidity like
what are the things that you can control
and the really you know you can play
around with titles and all of that but
honestly it's like how good are you at
what you're doing and i think when you
place your focus on just creating the
best content possible that's the
long-term strategy that you know i've
i've sort of adhered to and believe in
and as a result it's taken me a long
time i i didn't come out of the gate
swinging i didn't have a new york times
bestseller you know it's been kind of a
very plotting
path of just slowly brick by brick like
building something that is sustainable
over time and and meaningful
you said you talked about storytelling
and i get this question a lot because we
tell a lot of stories
and i think
now we're pretty good at it but i
definitely was not a storyteller growing
up i was the quiet kid and my group of
friends
in my house my sister was the if
something happened to me
and we wanted at a party we wanted to
tell the story it'd be like let your
sister like basically sister tell it
it'll be it'll be that's when it'll be
good and so
i was definitely not a storyteller kind
of like naturally um
but have tried to get better at it
because i think it's a really powerful
tool you talked about the same thing
like you know um if you'd like to convey
information if you'd like to inspire
people if you'd like to educate people
like you're going to want this tool in
your tool belt called storytelling
and you know work on that craft because
it will help you um
can you teach me a little bit about
storytelling so tell me
some things that you've learned either
how you learned it what you learned
help us be a better storyteller in a
couple minutes here what what are some
things that uh that come to mind
yeah that's a great that's a great
question i mean i i think storytelling
is a skill like i'm a naturally uh
you know quiet person myself i didn't
grow up
telling crazy stories around the
campfire you know and regaling my
friends or anything like that
i really learned i i think my kind of um
education around storytelling
began as somebody who who
has attended thousands if not tens of
thousands of aaa meetings and being
somebody who who had the privilege to
bear witness
to people
get up in front of groups large and
small and really bear their soul and and
tell their personal story warts and all
of you know the hardships that they've
endured and how they got better and kind
of arrived at the life that that they
enjoy today and that requires courage
and it requires most importantly
vulnerability like if you've been to nea
meetings and you see people up and they
get up and they tell the most horrific
stories about the things that they have
done things that would provoke a shame
response in any normal human being and
they laugh it off and you realize like
how powerful that is to
be so um
confident in yourself that you can share
this tale of something that you did and
it holds no power over you i think that
is a powerful kernel of transformation
for other people when they hear that
but to the vulnerability piece what it
taught me was the courage to be
vulnerable myself so that i could get up
in front of groups and tell my story
with that level of of honesty and
vulnerability
and also to notice that when you do that
you create
trust and connectivity in the person
that you're speaking to like if you're
willing to get up and tell them this
crazy thing that you did uh as an opener
it gives the other person permission to
do the same and that exchange then
becomes uh one that is much more
intimate than the typical conversation
that we're going to have so that's a key
piece like i always try to lead with
vulnerability and the second thing being
that that um you know everybody has
their version of joseph campbell's uh
hero's journey like we're all on our own
hero's journey of some sort
and to really kind of study and
understand the principles of what makes
a great story
helps you
extract it out of the person that you're
speaking with and also helps you learn
how to figure out what that is in your
own story and that just comes with
practice so
listen if i'm sitting across from you
know a doctor and they want to talk to
me about
the microbiome maybe that's not a hero's
journey story but maybe how they got
interested in that is you know i'm
always trying to find some
version mini or macro that i can tell
that will you know create engagement and
for myself and and also for the person
that's listening but i've also had the
privilege of and these are some of my
favorite episodes where i'm sitting down
with somebody who you know
was really broken in a certain way and
then rebuilt their life and became
something else entirely and that's a
great kind of
template for doing a full-blown joseph
campbell you know arc of the hero
and i think those stories are powerful
because
when somebody can see that type of
transformation and somebody who had it
way worse than they have it it raises
the you know their their own belief in
in themselves and i think you know to
really specifically answer your question
it's just a practice like i've been
doing this for 10 years like
i i would be horrified to go back and
listen to some of my first episodes so
you know i've learned in real time in a
public sphere but just like anything
else like you have to practice it and
figure out also
what works for you it's not oh i'm going
to follow this person did it and they
were successful so i'm going to do it
that way it's like what speaks to you
what is natural and authentic to who you
are and i think the more that you can
bring your own intuition and sensibility
and honesty into whatever it is that
you're trying to share with the world
that's going to be the the demarcation
that will distinguish you
from others
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
who do you think are great storytellers
like uh are there any people or books
that you learn from where you
you look at it and you sort of have
picked up things from from them
sure i mean i think malcolm gladwell is
a master storyteller uh we we we had the
privilege of just having him in here a
couple weeks ago and i mean nobody can
tell a story like that guy i mean he can
take people off the street and in five
minutes you know figure out something
absolutely fascinating about them that
will become an episode of revisionist
history you know and it's a i mean i
think he has
a talent uh that you know we can all
aspire to that probably we can't reach
but i think he's fantastic at it i think
um adam grant is a phenomenal
storyteller i mean some of the authors
that are you know working in social
psychology right now are are pretty good
great at storytelling but those would be
the two that that come to mind
and you i'm gonna read a quote from your
story um and i want you to basically uh
take me there and then uh where you came
so here's the quote
we had four kids we were so broke at one
point not long after my book came out we
had nothing to go on we ended up going
to kauai and living in yurts thinking we
may never come back to la and we were
going to lose our house
so what was that and then how did you
get from there to
here
yeah man that was uh that was rough so
it was very disorienting because
i had the opportunity to write this book
and i got like i mentioned earlier like
a decent advance for a first-time author
but
for kids and the way that publishing
advances work they dole it out in
increments over you know a good deal of
time and then taxes and agent cuts and
all of that it turns out to not be that
much
so
the book comes out
we're you know shoestringing to be able
to pay our bills
and a big theme in the book is this idea
that when you know and it's my story of
transformation that when
your heart is true the universe will
conspire to support you it's something i
i believe it's it's a it's a principle
i've seen um
uh you know come to play in many people
that i know and it's something that i
believed was happening in my own life
and would continue to happen and when
the book came out i decided i'm not
renewing my bar membership i'm going to
step into this new thing and i don't
know what it's going to what kind of
opportunities are going to come but i
need to be 100 available for them and i
was trusting i was like my heart is true
something is going to happen we're going
to figure this out um but you know i was
running a household with a relatively
high overhead at the time four kids a
mortgage and you know the the problem
with that equation is there's no
timeline on it and you know my edict has
has has borne out to be true over time
ten years later
but uh it was really rough for quite
quite an extended period of time we
couldn't pay our mortgage we had cars
repossessed i've told this story before
but
it was so bad at one point
um that you know we didn't have enough
money to pay for our our garbage
collection so they took away our bins we
had to put our our garbage bags in the
back of this beat up minivan that we had
and look for you know kind of uh bins
like behind the grocery stores and stuff
to like throw our garbage i mean it was
pretty humiliating and quite frankly
pretty emasculating as somebody who's
supposed to be
you know head of household and taking
care of [__] like i was unable to make
sure that my house was in order and so
we went through a really rough period of
time and
it was not clear that we were going to
be able to kind of persevere
we did get an opportunity a friend of
mine who's a high net worth individual
had
a property on the north shore of kauai
he was trying to figure out how to turn
it into some kind of community space and
he had read my book and had been
inspired he said why don't you come out
and help me figure out like what i can
do to transform this property into
something more meaningful than where i
live
and i don't know why he thought that i
would be somebody well suited for that
job it's not like i have any kind of
experience in that but essentially you
know in retrospect looking back like he
threw my family a lifeline and so yes we
moved to the north shore of kauai it was
a operating uh mango farm at the at the
at the time and the the kind of
um woofers who were working the farm
were living in these yurts behind the
main um
sort of dwelling at the on the property
and we moved into these yurts with these
young kids who were working the land
and spent a couple months where i was
trying to help this individual figure
out what to do with his property but
mainly he was paying me such that we
could pay her bills and when we went to
kauai we thought there's no way we're
going to save our house we haven't been
able to pay our mortgage in so long like
it's just not possible we may just be
here and this is where we're going to
live and after a couple of months
uh you know
of living out there i started to get a
creative itch like i had written this
book and i was trying to get some energy
going around like these ideas that were
important to me and i was feeling a
little bit of ivan island fever and
disconnected and stuff so that's when
the impetus to start the podcast happen
like i needed to do something creative
for myself and and you know i'll always
look back on that experience quite
romantically because it was it created
the perfect storm of events to create
this thing that has now
you know been successful beyond my
wildest imagination
and so let's break down the business
side of things so you have the content
which is like you said the tip of the
spear the top of the funnel where people
they sort of they discover you they
start to like you they start to trust
you love you and say oh wow this is
content that can really help me but then
you have these like really interesting
businesses right so you have um
you know you have the meal planning
business so like i don't know
meals.ritual.com or something like that
and so you have
you have a meal planning business you
charge you know i don't know 100 bucks a
year or something like that you help
people
um
you know go sort of plant-based in a way
that's gonna that's gonna work for them
uh you have this thing called the epic
five challenge which is uh five i don't
know what it is five iron man triathlons
or something like that in in five
like in five days what is it what is the
exact thing for epic five yeah
so just to be clear i don't have any
financial involvement in in that race
but yes so one of the things i did as an
athlete was this thing called epic five
where jason lester and i did five uh
iron distance triathlons on five
hawaiian islands the idea was to do it
in five days it took us a little bit
longer but in the wake of that
experience um it's become an annual
event that i'm not affiliated with
professionally but okay
all right so basically it's like mostly
the media company
um and then it's the meal planning
business
um
talk to us about like how you kind of
like you mentioned your mentor friend
who helped you kind of structure this
and set this up and figure out how to
actually build a
like a like a full like you know
thriving lifestyle going from living in
the yurt on the mango farm to like you
know
you know actualizing this idea um what
is that business what's the business
brain part of you you know how would you
explain that to the next person who
maybe they don't have that mentor maybe
they they see what you do but can you
explain it here and maybe there's out of
our audience some people out there who
can take that blueprint or that idea and
say okay i'm in a totally different
vertical or i'm you know i have some
differences but i can learn from how
he's architected this business
sure
so first of all that mentor then became
my business partner and that's a key
piece in all of this because without him
i probably would have never gotten out
of the gate and he's been my business
partner ever since and it's an amazing
relationship and what he brought to the
equation was not only
a sense of possibility but like i said
earlier like structure and that
structure has always been
grounded in real business fundamentals
and being patient and
and and and growing only incrementally
and not getting too excited about new
stuff and taking on too much so it's
been a slow growth curve but in
retrospect we've we i think we've made
really good decisions about how we've
invested our time and our energy and yes
it's now a very diversified
business that is fundamentally media
oriented
but we have a lot of different verticals
so yes the podcast is the tip of the
spear as i mentioned earlier it's the
thing that that drives everything else
and it's also the thing that generates
the most uh the most income the meal
planner does very well for us i love
that it's a low-cost entry to something
i think can be really transformational
in terms of people changing their habits
around food so that's a a you know an
integral piece in all of this and then
there's the books i mentioned finding
ultra but we also have
um
three cookbooks the plant power way the
plant power away italia and then my wife
wrote a book called this cheese is nuts
which is about how to make plant-based
cheese so we have the publishing end
and uh and she's gone off a good i feel
like i've heard that cookbooks could be
a bit like books may not books in
general may not be but cookbooks
specifically might actually be a good
business what teach us about that
because you know you don't run into too
many people you've done this
cookbooks are a very good business uh
it's it's hit or miss but if you hit
they can be massive um they're difficult
to put together because
beyond just the written words on the
page there's photography and there's
recipe testing and all of that so
there's a lot that goes into creating a
great cookbook but they're great
businesses and a big reason for that is
that if you do hit it they're perennial
sellers so they'll sell year after year
after year and how does that work so a
hit means what you get picked up with
like a good brick and mortar
distribution or is it mostly direct to
consumer like what is a hit what does it
look like when you get a hit
i think it depends on what your goals
and motivations are so our cookbooks
we've done with a major publisher avery
which is part of random house and we got
really nice advances for those books and
those books continue to sell and and do
well for us um they weren't they're not
they weren't neither of them were were
new york times bestsellers or anything
like that but the real mark of success i
think in publishing is whether or not
you create something that is perennial
so finding ultra for example we just hit
the decade mark on that and it continues
to sell
more and more every single year so even
though it wasn't huge out of the gate it
continues to find audiences and then it
becomes um you know just a revenue
stream for you for you quarter after
quarter so
those are those books but now we have we
have two other books that we've
self-published
called voicing change which are
uh coffee table versions of the podcast
with excerpts from our favorite guests
with amazing photography and essays
contributed by myself and some of the
guests that really act like keepsakes or
marketing tools for the podcast like
it's a it's a it's a collectible item
these books uh our motivation
or our definition of success for these
books is very different from the other
books because they're not intended to go
out and sell
to make the new york times best seller
list they have a very specific audience
in mind
and the fact that we created them
in-house means that it's a different
revenue model as well so we don't need
to sell as many of them to do well and
i'm really proud of those books we're
going to do another one this year and
create a box set and also when we work
with brands which is a big piece of of
our business as well it's great to be
able to send them the book and show them
that we're executing on a quality level
that i think no one else is doing in the
podcast space which helps distinguish us
from you know the zillions of other
podcasts that are out there because it's
very crowded right now and sends the
message that you know we're we're trying
to elevate a certain you know we're all
of our content is very elevated and that
you know we're operating from
a very professional perspective in
everything that we're doing
so that's the books and then we have
sorry go ahead on the books one second
so uh i'm fascinated by the books thing
i think it's uh really cool i think it's
a really cool art my wife is vegan also
she has we have maybe i don't know 10 15
really hi and she you know she loves the
it's like a coffee table book and a
cookbook at the same time like it's
gotta have the like premium sort of
finish and uh photography it's very
aspirational and has a
guy who barely you know knows how to use
a frying pan and like you know i don't
know i eat like i eat like a college kid
sometimes it's like i see this it was so
different for me so i started getting
curious about this cookbook she was
buying and this who are these people
behind this now are those perennials
just because
you have a growing audience and so like
your audience grows every year and it's
like one percent of your audience buys
your stuff and you are that's you are
the sales as well as the
and so that's why they keep climbing or
is it kind of like independent in a way
like obviously that contributes but like
is there a separate engine that lets
those continue to grow or is it just
your main engine of like my podcast
grows therefore
one percent of people will go buy the
cookbook every year
yeah i think it's a little bit of both i
mean with finding ultra which is a
memoir i think the continued sales of
that book
are are are really uh due to the growing
platform that we've created here the
cookbooks are a little bit different um
it's of course you know in part because
of the platform and we use the platform
to you know
sort of occasionally uh you know promote
the books but i think in tandem with
that we've seen
um a real mainstreaming of plant-based
lifestyle in a way that didn't exist
back in 2012 2014 more and more people
are interested in this lifestyle and
diet
which means that those those cookbooks
retain relevancy
and have you um
like have you done have you launched any
businesses or products like this that
have just flopped like you know
the version of the the cookbook that
like you were excited about you even
maybe liked the product it just didn't
work or have you been pretty
uh high hit rate with with what you guys
have launched outside like you know like
in additional products
yeah i mean i think you know early on in
this process we launched uh
uh a couple supplements like a protein
powder and i thought maybe like
nutraceuticals might be something that i
would be interested in doing and i
quickly lost interest in that um it was
modestly successful
but i realized that
it was a very crowded marketplace and
there were people who were doing really
good work in that area and i was more
interested in the media and if i was not
at the um
at the plants like at the manufacturing
location overseeing all of this and
really being detail oriented around it
uh there was too much risk of
shenanigans because i was not in control
of the manufacturing process and there's
a lot of weird stuff that goes on in
that world when you're licensing these
labs to create something for you and it
felt like my risk exposure was too high
and i just realized i didn't want to
unless i was going to go all in on that
it didn't make sense and so we abandoned
that
we have other you know we sell some swag
and some t-shirts and things like that
on the website they don't do fantastic
but it's nice to have them there so you
know
not everything is a huge smash success
but sometimes some of these smaller
verticals still make sense nonetheless
right and you're if you were doing a pie
chart is it like
these the meal planning and the
cookbooks and all that stuff that's cool
but like in reality if we drew the pie
chart is it like
podcasts or you know the media side is
with the sponsors is ninety percent of
it anyways or is it fairly
like uh diversity beyond that
um i would say
the podcast is maybe i don't know i
should do a pie chart so i know this
better but it's probably you know around
uh
80 to 85 percent of it but the other
the other revenue generators are public
speaking which is growing a lot
so we do quite well there and
and you know the the the podcast model
is an advertising model so that money
comes from sponsors but i also have
relationships with a handful of sponsors
outside of the podcast context where i'm
represented as as an athlete for example
like with solomon um so that's another
kind of way that we um
you know grow the business that isn't
necessarily directly related to the
podcast itself and then we have retreats
so we do these covid really sidelined
this part of our business but we're
getting back to it next spring
where my wife and i take groups of
people uh
to a location in italy and have a
week-long experience with food and
meditation and running and the su and
such stuff like that when we have guests
on the pod i find that they typically
fall into two buckets
and both i um
admire there's what i'll call the kind
of like expected bucket like on a
business oriented podcast which is a
person comes on
they have a product or a story so far
that's like exciting and momentum and
you know what's admirable about them is
their you know ambition they basically
they never stop dreaming bigger
and um they see you know no limit and
they are chasing that that sort of
limitless uh vision where you you walk
away from the podcast and you feel like
oh man i've been thinking small right
and that's a great feeling it's not a
negative feeling it's oh wow the the the
pie is even bigger than i could have
imagined the possibilities are different
than what i had been kind of come to
accept an example would be a buddies
with the founder of uh calm and i
remember even very early on when that
app it's a meditation app and now it's
very very big it's probably a you know
one to three billion dollar company but
they early on when they could they could
barely get an investor to give them a
check uh it was like just a couple guys
in their apartment there was there
really wasn't much to going for it
even back then i remember
um michael talking about like we're
gonna have an island someday like a calm
island like you know like coachella like
festivals right but instead of craziness
like instead of rowdy we're gonna be
selling calm as a festival and we're
gonna do it on our own island and it's
gonna be like disney world for com and
like we're gonna build a nike level
brand and he was talking about that back
then and you know when he said it back
then he seemed a little nuts and now you
know he says it now and he's a visionary
but he's been saying the same thing for
like 10 years and so that's an example
of the high ambition path uh that i
admire and the other one is
the person who's
uh you know
like high contentedness and they're like
well
um i really love what we're doing
i don't know if we'll do more haven't
really thought about it um
maybe we will but you know here are my
principles and you know they're
they're admirable and how grounded they
are and that they have found you know
some version of enough for them and they
are not like you know trying to take
over the world
which part of that spectrum do you lean
more towards when it comes to business
yeah that's a great question i i i lean
more towards the latter um but maybe not
all the way on that side i mean i'm
certainly not the guy who's dreaming
about islands and private jets and
things like that people ask me all the
time like what's the vision like what
you know where do you see yourself in
five years and
i always feel
weird or guilty because i don't have a
good answer for that and i and i
realized like oh it's just because i
don't i don't really think that way like
i'm focused on how i can be better today
than i was yesterday i'm focused on how
to enhance the quality of what i'm
sharing with the world
and i'm focused on trying to be grateful
and content with what i have and not be
jealous or envious of what other people
who have more than me have because
that's just a dangerous place for me as
a recovering alcoholic and just as a
human being so i am competitive like i'm
not averse to looking at the rankings on
apple podcast and
getting you know frustrated because
somebody's ahead of me who i don't think
is deserving of it like you know i can
be incredibly petty that way
but but honestly like for the most part
like i'm i'm just so grateful to be in
the position that i'm in and i'm not
doing this to get to another place like
if this is all that it is like it's been
a pretty [__] good ride and i'm
stoked to be able to wake up every day
and come in and talk to amazing people
and if i can continue to do this and
that's again like all that it is like
that's a damn good run right now there
are you know creative things that i want
to express and they're not about chasing
money they're more like uh
you know just inspirations that i have
like oh it would be cool to do this or
can i carve out enough bandwidth so i
can explore this other thing that that
is interesting to me right now so it's
much more of kind of an artist path of
of of following my gut and what gets me
excited rather than here's a new
business because i i think we could ease
we could have easily
complicated what we're doing right now
and created a network and you know
started you know having other people
create podcasts and and you know
building an entity that we could sell to
spotify or something like that but
that's not really
where my heart is or or where my head is
so
um i don't know if that answers your
question but yeah think about it
you know um
one thing that i always like to talk to
different guests that come on about is
like you know you live in a different
world than me therefore you see
different things
and you see different problems and
opportunities and trends that
uh me over here i'm not seeing because
i'm just focused on other things and so
um i'm curious either you can take it in
either direction you can either take it
in a trend so like let's say
maybe 2012
uh maybe you might have said you know
what there's a really passionate
community of plant-based uh you know
around this plant-based lifestyle and i
think this is gonna get bigger i think
people are gonna more people are gonna i
think this might catch on and more
people are going to you know
uh wander this way um
so it's either a trend you notice that
like oh there's a group of people who
really care about this or there's a
movement happening that i find very
interesting but ultra marathons whatever
it is
um the second option the second thing uh
direction is just here's a gap i see so
whereas our audience is heavily
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs people
who
they live to solve problems and you know
i like to bring their attention to
problems worth solving or you know
things that are missing from different
parts of the world rather than
uh maybe you know the 10 000 to do to-do
list app or whatever you could you could
go build and so taking it either
direction what comes to mind when i
either say what trends and movements
have you been noticing
uh or what gaps um or opportunities do
you see in your in your world
yeah i mean i think i
to answer that question um
my head naturally goes to um two
polarities young people and people that
are getting older so i'm a little bit
older than you so my interest is going
to be around areas of of longevity and
meaning in a way that maybe you know you
you're not in a position to really have
to entertain in a meaningful way yet um
and then with young people
it's equally about meaning so what i see
happening right now on a macro level is
a whole generation of young people who
are coming up
um into a world and thinking about their
professional trajectory in the context
of meaning in a way that was not really
part of the thought process of my
generation being gen x they don't want
to just find the best job that's going
to pay them the most they want to plug
in to the thing that uh feels like it's
making a difference in the world in a
positive way and i think that's really
cool it's easy to make fun of gen z and
uh you know a lot of the kind of tropes
around you know where young people are
at right now but i'm very inspired by
that sensibility because it was lacking
in you know kind of my
my um
you know the the on you of the gen x
which was to not what was cool was to
not care about anything and to be
cynical and so you know i'm very
refreshed by that um focus that i see in
so many young people and i and i think
on the other extreme with people that
are you know more in my age bracket who
have kind of been in the professional
world done whatever they're gonna do
and are are realizing to some degree
or or not like
how happy am i how much meaning has this
path that i chose for myself given me
and whether or not i stay in this path
or find something new how can i bring
more meaning into my lived experience
both professionally and and and socially
for the decades to follow and i see
shared dna between that young cohort and
that older cohort and what i make of
that is this
um groundswell
of interest in
happiness contentment
and the um the pillars of what it means
to pursue a life that will um not just
sustain you but really allow you to feel
authentically expressed in in who you
are
i like that uh and if you were
um
kind of like not if not the so it's not
the sort of question like if you were 21
again today what would you go do but
sort of like
um how would you act on that so you
observed this behavioral mindset shift
in both let's say the older generation
and the younger generation
um what do you do with that how would
you
what is the rich role approach to acting
on that insight
as a young person yeah if you just as a
person with time on there yeah it
doesn't matter how old you are just as a
person who yeah if you didn't have like
a thousand things to do and you weren't
already committed to xyz job or project
you so you had some freedom and you were
interested in that you saw that at that
observation what would you do to act on
it how would you approach it yeah
i mean i think with with young people
one thing i always tell young people is
to invest in experience and and opt out
of the pressures of the rat race to plug
right into some kind of career
trajectory
because there's an undue
expectation with young people that
they're supposed to know who they are
and what they want to do with their
lives at an age when their brains are
are barely formed and you know i think
it's important for young people to go
out and have as many experiences as
possible
before they make a certain particular
choice about how they want to live their
life because how can you make that
choice until you've been exposed to a
lot of different things until you've
traveled and spent time with all
different kinds of people
for the older people i think it's about
reprogramming you like if you've been on
a certain path and trajectory for a very
long time we become very calcified
around who we think we are and we have
to free ourselves from that narrative or
that story and begin to build the muscle
of connecting with our intuition and
starting to bring expression to the
things that um that i think innately
bring us joy that perhaps we've
we've kind of repressed or or put in the
rear view mirror because we haven't had
the time or the energy or the money or
whatever to indulge them and on the
subject of indulgence to disabuse people
of the idea that it is an indulgence or
that it is selfish so you know the the
the the path i think for that person
is to really start paying attention
um to themselves to what gets them
excited to
things that you know they just find
themselves naturally
inclined towards and to start to you
know water that garden or feed that
energy because i think in doing that it
kind of leads you on a path towards some
form of expression that will ultimately
you know bring meaning and and greater
fulfillment into your life
well i think that's a good place to to
close it rich thanks for coming on man i
i really appreciate it um give people a
shout out where they should find you or
subscribe to the podcast where do you
want to direct people if they want more
yeah sure thanks for having me the it's
just richroll.com r-i-c-h-r-o-l-l
dot com is my website where you can find
everything the rich world podcast
uh which is available wherever you
listen to podcasts and the youtube
channel richroll.com uh those are those
would be the places and uh you can learn
all about me there
awesome thanks so much
cool thank you really appreciate talking
to you that was super fun
[Music]
you